menstrual hygiene is a very very taboo
job in in our area i mean you cannot
talk to the man
about the menstrual periods or any kind
of issue
[Music]
karma thank you so much for joining me
on my show how are you
i'm really great i'm doing good it's
beautiful
here in california so yeah
it's it's nice yeah i i
thank you so much for joining me all the
way from california but really what
we're talking about is not california
we're going to talk about india today
right
because you're doing some fascinating
work with it with india and helping a
lot of people
both locally and at scale so i want to
just dive straight into it
maya tell me a little bit about your
journey and how do you get to
work in rural india and helping a lot of
women
yes so michael i am born and brought up
in india it's a very small village
called maharagam
and it's like you can't even find in the
google map
and that's where i grew up and i came
all the way
there to united states and then
i study um science and then i was doing
my
uh psd program in south dakota
after two years uh i dropped it and i
joined the research here
and one thing i realized like how many
people come comes from that far
to here and pursue their study and have
a good life
and the things are same in my village
back
back in my village and and problems are
rising so i thought like
let's let's give some try and you know
just uh
serve those people so i went back to my
village
searched about the problems i knew also
because i grew up there
so then i find out like okay these are
the
bigger issues which i can uh you know
walk
easily because nothing is like
difficult for me since i know the people
language and
culture and everything so then i started
with this
project called menstrual hygiene
awareness
affordability and availability these
three things like
it has to be there because in the remote
area
everywhere uh this is the women heisen
women hygiene is a big issue everywhere
uh most most of the party so tell me a
little bit about
about this big issue what what why what
is the issue and
and what what is the scale of it as well
because you know coming
from a place that's it's a little far
away
it's it's a little you know distant from
my understanding so share with me a
little bit
about what's actually happening yes so
the thing is like
uh earlier time like if we talk about
like our grandma's time
that time they were like you know very
very uh eq
with the cotton clothes we all know like
you know all
old peop all old time the women they
used to have
uh the good cotton in in in the
abundance that they can change
that cloth every time they can dry and
they had that
kind of a freedom but the over the time
uh
we replaced that cotton with the
synthetic with the other materials
and then families getting you know
divided and then
there the women's space got very very
small and now the new modern india
so called like the architecture of the
houses
they are building such a way that you
can't dry
that clothes in a sun and it is a big
taboo in india
so if you can't dry and you can't wash
that clothes then
it will be making you sick and nowadays
it's very very short because one woman
is using the same clothes over and
over and over and over and especially in
the
rainy season it gets really moistures
and that's how they got
uti rti cervical cancer
and so many other stuff so this is the
major
and because of the biggest population in
india
um like we are we are billions in in
india so
it's hard to reach out the sanitary pad
to each and everyone
in the remote in the travel area so most
of the women who are living in
outside like outskirt countryside they
don't even know what is sanitary pad
and if they know the sanity pad it is so
expensive that
they they don't they can't even afford
it because
it's a it comes with the it it doesn't
come with the livelihood because they
had to arrange first the food
and then only they can think about other
stuff
so most of the population can't afford
such a expensive pads and if they can
afford then
it's not available there so then we
started thinking about it
and then we thought like you know you
know how to solve this
problem in our area actually
so so tell me a little bit about this
problem solving
thinking first of all what is the how
would you define
the scale of this problem so how many
people do you think
are are lacking this proper hygiene or
sanitation right now because of these
different norms
uh in modern india how big is this
voluntary tackling
so the problem is really really huge
the the data says like is still in
the modern age in india all the rural
place
70 percent population is still not
getting the
hygiene hygienic stuff 70 percent
in the village in the rural india
they are not getting the sanity pad or
or any hygienic stuff
so the problem is very very big very
very high
and i tell you like 12 girls they drop
out because of this
issue because in in the school when they
get the periods
they don't have pads they use the
clothes and then they go to
school and school doesn't have uh
twilights
and you know comfort kind of a
place where they can change so they
don't go to school
and then finally they drop out so 12
percent girls
they don't want from the school because
of the sanitary pad
unbelievable and so tell me a little bit
about your experience how do you even
get involved with thinking about a
problem like this
and and knowing that this is something
that you're passionate about solving
yeah because this relate to my own story
when i was growing up in those areas i
also
i was also one of them in my team so in
my high school i also faced
the similar issues like you know using
the clothes and very hard time
for you know drying them and if they dry
then it's
hard to keep them like six six hours or
so
so all these difficulties i went through
and then you know over the time i also
got some kind of infections and all
issues like the other women's and then
because i was i was always worked in a
hospital in the medical research so i
thought like
i may can solve these issues because
this is this relate
to me this is my very very intimate um
you know issue that i can understand
other girls other women
so then i went went there and then i
talked to the women's and
and he heard their issues their problems
and then we thought like okay uh
how can we go one by one one step at the
time then we
find out like you know you know who's
the guy he's uh i mean
who's the guy um working on this these
issues
then i travel all over india find out
some people
and one of them is like arunacharam he's
the guy
um whose biopic is very very
famous it's called padman so it it is
like
one of the big block western in india um
so so that guy i met and he he was kind
of inspirational
and then i i started you know arranging
machines the materials and the women's
and the trainings and
scalabilities and everything so it's
around like six seven years journey
yeah so you're saying it as if it's a
you know very very simple yeah
scalability and the technology or
anything but
but i would love to hear that story
because i think that's really where it
gets fascinating how you can actually
take this idea take this pollen and and
bring it to fruition and find create a
product that actually
makes such a such a strong impact
especially in a population
where it's not the same thing as
creating a product and marketing it to a
bunch of you know
consumers right in the united states
it's a different type of problem
it's a different type of distribution
and so tell me first a little bit about
the solution that you found and then i
would love to really talk about the
distribution and the scalability of it
how do you get it to to all these women
and because it's a again it's
it's a very different industry from from
those that i'm used to
yes so it is completely different
because it's a hygiene
kind of uh industry and and very
few people work for for that issues
because you know all the multi
uh company come forward and then they
take over this but
now the the problem is uh first of all
in our area
it's like agricultural area and the
income
of the per family capital is very very
less and the
they they mostly spend in like you know
food and arranging other stuff
so the women hygiene comes at the very
last end
like here in the united states we live
here we include the sanitary pad and all
the hygiene stuff
in our monthly budget so we buy at the
same time like you know when we are
buying our groceries or
vegetables or other things but not in
india it's not even considered like
it is a things to to buy so the thing is
like
when the women they are not getting they
are not getting on the time they are not
educated they are not aware we didn't
had a
any kind of a syllabus in our book
right up to 10th grade that the hygiene
should be
you know included and this is the
prominent issues and
all the girls they should learn about uh
this thing in
a school so this is like really big
issues in in our like you know community
so then what i thought like okay how
difficult it is right because i'm
i'm already working in a science site
and medical side and other stuff
that time i was working in ucsf so then
i spoke to the local people like
how big it this taboo is and it is a big
taboo because nobody wants to talk about
this
problem so first thing you are a local
and you need to
you need to talk to the people and
convince them that
like i really want to work on these
issues in this area only
because i can work anywhere in india but
why i chose my
own district location hometown area
because i understand people and i want
to solve that
problem from that community so then we
arrange the machines and then
you know uh the material which comes all
the way from china as we all know like
it's all
uh standard and then we we find out the
good machines and
and we uh hired the women who are
actually looking for a job they are like
a daily worker they
daily wage workers so amazing yeah so we
hired them
we trained them how what is a hygiene
how to make sanity pads
it's a very small scale that we were we
were working earlier but then slowly
we gave them you know confidence like
hey this is your products
you are gonna work here and we we
gave the brand is called no tension
sanity pad
and they got like very happy like hey
this is our own products we
are making and we are distributing so
then then that got
like really really um
around the the cities and then the
villages and then we reach out to the
more women
more uh women because in india the
sector is divided like the
the men's they work in a different parts
and the women they works in a different
uh work it's it's like like the industry
side
you will find the more men and the less
women but then
agriculture there is like 50 50 50. and
then there are some certain
uh groups in the all the villages like
asha kari karta ashawaka
those groups they are only for the women
so
so the women to women it's it's easy to
spread out the word spread out the
products
and after that after manufacturing the
path
then i thought like maybe uh the
education is the most important key
to you know educate them about the
awareness
how to use pads how to dispose the pad
because
the environmental issue is also coming
up in a landfilling
and plastics and all that so we need to
approach in a holistic way where we are
giving the solution
also we are giving the the uh
other solution to dispose the sanitary
pad
because in india we don't have like you
know uh things like
separation and segregations and all that
we dump
at the one place or be barn at the one
place so this is how
this this was very critical because you
know the awareness and the education
part
so i took the pledge that i will go
around that area
and stay on the road for like you know
couple of months and
and educate all the schools and the
girls hostel and the tribal area in
terms of uh
the menstrual hygiene like the the
awareness
program so we designed the program we
designed the material
and then uh i went to 15 tribal area
stayed there for a few days and then you
know
take the workshop and and the
conferences and the
classes in all the you know girl kind of
a
hostel so you can meet like larger
population from a different villages
you train all the girls like hey how to
spread this message how to reach out to
other
women in your village exactly
so this is this program went like really
very very successful and all the media
is covered
and and it came in in the local news so
that other people also they were reading
and this was kind of eye-openers and
that time the movie was coming like
padman so
eventually my name uh came up as a pad
women of india so this was
this was the the time where i spent most
of the time on the
road and then i was and and then i
spread out like you know i
i reach out to thousands of girls
women's needy they had
millions of questions like hey why this
happens why that happens
and so many and unfortunately there is
no system where they can
they can ask their queries and they can
get the right answer
and they can study well because you know
when you have something in your mind and
you are
you're not getting answer on time then
you cannot focus on your study or in
your
you know daily to day to day uh life so
this is how like you know we
we spread out this awareness programs
and the
sanitary pads all over the places
i i think that's just remarkable tell me
a little bit about the the most
difficult thing that you've encountered
throughout this process because
you make it sound you know relatively uh
relatively okay but but i'm sure that it
was
incredibly difficult i mean you're
talking about if
having to find a holistic approach to
you know solving like an incredible need
within a country that has you know
billions of people
and you're talking about something with
the population that doesn't necessarily
have the also
you know funds and and education to
start with so
i'd love to hear a little bit about the
the greatest challenges that you've had
along the way
yeah so the challenges is like i mean if
i work in a
in a san francisco i have a excellent
like you know teams i can find
i can hire the people i can uh get the
best of best
uh you know uh talent here
but when you when you go to the
grassroot level
work in a very very like you know deep
into interior
you had a very hard time to find the
suitable person for the suitable job
so this was my biggest challenge that i
cannot find the
accountant i cannot find the computer
guy i cannot find the data entries
because
you're living in with with nothing
there's no i mean hardly electricity
and and you have challenges like you
know network and so many things so
getting the right team on the right time
uh understanding you know they would
they would understand your issue and you
would understand their
their their issue it's a difficult part
and then other
difficult one was because menstrual
hygiene
is a very very taboo job in in our uh
area i mean you cannot talk to the man
about the menstrual
periods or any kind of issue
convincing them telling them hey this is
your family issue this is your
maybe mom issues sister issues wife
issues
you we need to speak up about it and
then sometimes they get like you know
they hide
um they just you know feel shy and
even the women also they feel very shy
like if you if you go to the room
and where 10 20s women are sitting and
you start
speaking about the period they will go
away
so you cannot do that you had to relate
with something to something to something
and then you come up on the on the real
uh talk like the periods and and other
sort of issue
because it's it's a very very big taboo
and fighting
uh on that is like it's a hard
so these kind of issues i faced in the
beginning but when
you open about yourself you train like
women
and then 10 people other they are
speaking
with you with the same issue then people
will believe like hey
this is something that we really need to
listen this is something we really need
to talk
so so these are these are the issues uh
which i go i got i'm still facing the
challenges to get the right team to get
the right people
for my job in the scalability is very
difficult
so slowly we are training people slowly
slowly we are involving
right so then then you know things will
improve i know it will be never ending
challenge
uh for for us yeah
and unbelievable i have to say that that
it's inspiring to hear the the both the
challenges but also
you know the incredible work that you're
doing over there i think it's it's
incredibly innovative and and to me
personally it's inspiring to see
somebody who goes after such a such an
important uh topic from the get-go
and i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time in the past 20
minutes
i'd love for you to share with me three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
so in three words i i can say that
i am very fearless uh very confident
and very uh i would say
the learner for a lifetime so these are
the three words
which i want to conclude this
amazing maya thank you very very much
this was wonderful continue
making such a positive impact and stay
safe and stay healthy
yeah youtube thank you so much happy
holiday and
happy new year in advance
[Music]
you